le smart smart smart chacun son tour à
60 kilomètres d'orléans nouvelle virée
en famille pour aurélie et ses quatre
enfants
le défi du jour proposé aux enfants une
visite ludique et intéressante de l'un
des plus beaux châteaux de france
salut tout le monde on est au château de
blois c'est une grande première en hiver
7 comptant et là on va se dépêcher
d'aller aux toilettes parce que après
deux heures de rouler c'est merci
au coeur du monument sera content huit
siècles d'histoire royal l'édifice a été
construit à partir d'une neuvième siècle
en plein coeur de la cité pour démarrer
la visite
aurélie a rendez vous avec séverine
aurélien sauter enchanté moi c'est
séverine et je suis guide au château de
blois
on va le découvrir ensemble parle un
petit peu de son histoire
t rois des reines qui ont vécu vous avez
vu la grosse tour qui est derrière ça
vous dirait d'aller tout en haut un
parce que le château de blois c'est un
château du moyen âge cette forteresse 7
mai nous reste sept tours là qui à peu
près 700 ans séverine anime les visites
familiales et pour capter l'attention de
quatre enfants pleins d'énergie
elle a plus d'un tour dans son sac c'est
un peu magique
certaines portes où tout le monde ne va
pas une portable ses crêpes ça c'est
trop bien la tour du foie est le dernier
vestige du château datant du moyen-âge
ça sent le vieux ici le ding et dong
c'est trop trop trop beau il était à peu
près comme ça il ya 700 ans château
d'accord et nous on est en haute tour la
même chapelle bois il ressemblait un
château fort on a commencé la visite ils
sont captivés
la tour a fait son petit effet
cette fois ont vécu à blois françois 1er
en a fait sa résidence royale à la
renaissance et a fait construire toute
une aile alors donc les enfants jouent
entre l'al portrait de françois 1er en
vous voyez juste devant vous cette
partie là du château elle a été
construit pour lui c'était il ya cinq
cents ans
ça fait beaucoup loi mais la troupe
d'aurélie n'est pas très concentré
ici vous fait rire je crois qu'il est à
bout oui vous les trouvez un peu moi
c'est les corps un peu moins beau
françois 1er ça se passe super bien
ils sont passionnés par l'histoire de
séverine et tant qu'à les tient en
haleine comme ça tout ira bien
[Musique]